in stage for the complications in higher
stakes we see how the obstacles get
bigger and bigger and bigger they come
closer and closer together to make the
to accelerate the pace until finally
what's going to happen is the hero
encounters an obstacle that it's going
to be impossible to overcome and this is
the moment that I call the major setback
it's something again that happens to the
hero and at that moment your reader and
your audience must believe that there's
now no possibility of the hero
succeeding it seems like all is lost and
that's what the hero believes as well
and what the major setback is in this
movie is the officer who he was going to
call on the stand who is the only one
that would tell him the truth about the
Code Red being ordered by Jessup
Markinson is the character's name he
killed himself he was the night before
he was supposed to go testify he kills
himself now their only witness to what
really happened is gone and so we have
this scene right after that suicide
where he comes back and he informs
Galilean weinberg about what happened
he's drunk and he is just railing about
what occurred and he says I'm giving up
he yells at her and so on what he's
doing is he's reacting to the major
setback by retreating because when your
hero encounters this big obstacle and
gets thrown by it they're going to
attempt to go back to the life they were
living at the beginning he's going to go
attempt to go back and be the in his
identity the hotshot lawyer doesn't care
of anything he says I can't do anything
for them there's no hope I'm going to
give up I'm no good and so on and it
seems like all is lost their response is
going to be to retreat they're going to
give up and they're going to attempt to
go back to where they were at the
beginning of the story in the setup so
he go wants to go back he wants to give
up on his clients and say there's
nothing I can do he wants to just I he
doesn't even say what he's going to do
just let him be found guilty because he
has no
hope but he's also trying to retreat
into his identity he no longer is
willing to move into that essence that
he steadily been moving into where he
really is a good lawyer where he really
is risky not being as good as his father
was what he's really willing to face
that fear and be courageous enough to
overcome it but once he encounters this
and he knows they're going to lose
because he has no witness he wants to go
back so he gets drunk and he yells at
them until they insult Galloway deeply
and says there's no point in doing this
and so on he's just very meaning and so
Galloway leaves with this great light
and sawyer classier set of steak knives
because that was a joke he made earlier
in his Flint but way so he leaves any
sitting there with weinberg and then we
learned more about his father we've
already know his father was the the
Attorney General but there's a moment
when he says you know I think my father
would have been proud of me I think it
would have made him happy to see me
graduate from law school that's all he
ever says about his father but we see
that there's something he lost with his
father dying as as early as he did
before he finished law school part of it
at least was he went to law school to
make his father proud so obviously that
was something he deeply wanted and
didn't get to have especially if he was
so intimidated by his father and his
father had so many expectations that he
didn't think he was good enough and
that's what instill this whole identity
and so Weinberg says you know I did a
paper on your father once he was one of
the greatest lawyers ever he was one of
the greatest criminal defense lawyers
ever and he says but if I were these two
guys if I were down in Dawson the two
Marines who've been accused and I had a
choice between being defended by your
father and being defended by you I take
you any day of the week and twice on
Sunday and that's this reflection
character saying I see the truth of who
you are I see your essence you're the
one who can do
you're better than your father was you
can't let that stop you and that's
everything that that done Galloway has
been saying to him the whole movie
you're good up there in court I can see
the effect you have you're a great
lawyer she's told him in the past so
when he hears that then he finally
realizes okay I can't give up and now he
goes he moves in to stage 5 which is the
final push he's going to put everything
on the line to achieve this goal or die
trying he goes and gets Galilee says I'm
sorry I said that I'm going to put
jessep on the stand because that's the
most dangerous thing you can do because
if he doesn't get Jessup to confess then
he can be arrested in court-martialed
for accusing an officer of committing a
felony and that's what's going to bring
us to the final push and the climactic
moment in the movie
you